practiquemos un poco a nombrar los
compuestos iónicos aquí tenemos la
fórmula de un compuesto iónico pero como
se llama si se sienten inspirados pause
en el vídeo e inténtenlo ustedes mismos
bueno podemos ver que este compuesto
tiene magnesio y fósforo y en español se
acostumbre a escribir el guión positivo
después del negativo entonces en este
caso el guión positivo es nuestra
ocasión y si analizamos el magnesio en
la tabla periódica es lógico que sea
nuestra ocasión porque es un elemento
del grupo 2 es un metal alcalino terio y
cuando esos elementos se ionizan pierden
2 electrones que son los 2 electrones
que tienen en su última capa de
electrónica entonces cuando se ioniza
los pierde así que cuando el magnesio se
ioniza nos queda como magnesio dos más y
cada uno de estos tres iones de magnesio
probablemente son iones de magnesio dos
más entonces sí que
para entender mejor lo que sucede en
este compuesto
podríamos escribirlo así que no es la
forma común de verlo pero así podemos
ver fácilmente cuáles son los iones que
constituyen a este compuesto ahora como
mencioné el camión se escribe después
entonces simplemente tenemos magnesio y
el avión se escribe primero que en este
caso es el fósforo y es lógico que el
fósforo sea una unión bueno el fósforo
se encuentra del lado derecho de la
tabla periódica y para completar su
última capa electrónica o mejor dicho
capa de valencia sólo necesita ganar 1 2
3 electrones entonces cuando se ioniza
tiene sentido que quiera ganar esos 3
electrones con lo que el fósforo se
convierte en fósforo
3 - entonces los dos fósforos de esta
fórmula los podemos escribir así tenemos
2 años es fósforo
y esta y la razón por la que lo escribí
así fue para asegurarnos de que el
compuesto es neutro porque miren los
tres iones de magnesio tienen una carga
neta de 6 + y los dos fósforos tienen
una carga neta de 6 - entonces al sumar
6 más y 6 menos se cancelan vamos a
escribirlo tenemos 6 más y después
tenemos 6 menos y esto nos hace sentir
bien porque estamos entendiendo a este
compuesto iónico porque un compuesto
iónico bueno al menos aquí no
escribieron alguna carga así que esto
será neutro los cationes y los aviones
se cancelan pero como le llamamos a esto
bueno lo que se acostumbra es escribir
el nombre elemental del camión que en
este caso es magnesio magnesio y antes
de eso escribimos la versión puro de
lannion entonces si en este caso tenemos
fósforo nos queda como fósforo
fósforo de magnesio y tal vez me digan
oye esto no tiene mucha información si
alguien me dice fósforo de magnesio cómo
puedo regresar a la fórmula que teníamos
originalmente bueno la respuesta es que
pueden decir ok el magnesio es nuestro
catión que se encuentra aquí en el grupo
2 y tendrá una carga 2 positiva cuando
se ioniza entonces obtenemos esto y
después pueden decir bueno el fósforo
generalmente tiene una carga 3 - cuando
se ioniza que es lo que tenemos aquí y
después pueden decir ok y qué proporción
tengo que tener entre estas dos cosas
para que se cancelen bueno por cada 3
magnesio necesitamos dos fósforos y así
es como se van a cancelar así es como
podemos pasar del nombre a la fórmula y
eso es lo que haremos en otro vídeo